the Home Secretary visited Rwanda she
said migrants could be deported there
within months
um at the same time though this policy
has been in action since April no one
has actually left to Rwanda yet you'll
forgive me for my skepticism
well the first thing I should say is and
I think I've been in your show before
when you've talked about these huge
numbers of migrants we're determined to
grip this problem and stop the boats now
Rwanda forms one part of that the reason
why we haven't been able to proceed with
Rwanda is because it's currently before
the courts we actually succeeded at the
high court stages before the court of
appeal but as soon as that process is
through and I'm confident our policy is
lawful we will get cracking straight
away with the Rwanda policy and use that
as a tool in our army essentially what
we're saying and this comes through in
the legislation as well that we
announced earlier this month you cannot
come to this country by crossing the
channel and if you do so you'll either
be repatriated to your home country or
you'll be sent to Aranda so it's part of
that mix but it sits alongside other
things we've done so for example the
Albania deal where we're seeing many
flights going back to Albania already or
the work that's been done with the
French all of this is demonstration of
the government gripping this problem and
stopping the boats anyone who comes to
the country on a small boat that
includes children who come with their
families you personally comfortable with
that idea that I don't relish any of
this and I really wish we didn't have to
do it and the government isn't running
to do this the government is doing this
because this is a major
problems
we are being forced to do it and I'll
tell you why we're being forced to it I
think with those children seeking to
cross the channel I think of the danger
that their lives are being put in the
evil people Smugglers and whose hands
their place and unless we are willing as
a government and as a country to take
tough action in relation to this the
numbers will keep on growing and more
people's lives will be put at risk
including the lives of young children
and I'm simply not willing to allow that
to happen if there's a
great policy then why do the Home
Secretary only invite right-leading
media organizations to Rwanda with her
GB news the Sun the express the mail on
that play not Sky News not the BBC not
the eye or the guardian why are you
scared of scrutiny forgive me I don't
know the details of who the Home
Secretary
and I've heard the visit the the details
that you've given me the logistics of a
trip are a matter for the home so it's
probably not in for the Home Secretary
for her her operations team I'm sure
there'll be plenty of opportunities uh
for the BBC and for Sky to scrutinize
the home sector about it and indeed you
have me uh in front of you this morning
to talk to you and I'm delighted to be
on sky as I always am I do and I'm glad
you're delighted to run the program but
we've never had the chance to screw I
have never had a chance to scrutinize a
Home Secretary on this it's going
alongside others not invited on that
trip it does look like you're running
away from scrutiny
well as I said you Sophie I simply uh
don't know the details of individual
operational decisions but I'm very happy
for our policy to be scrutinized because
I'm confident that under Rishi sunak as
our prime minister we are gripping this
problem we're taking difficult decisions
as you rightly highlighted but we're
determined to stop this evil traffic
continuing Zoella Brotherman on this
visit visited some of the potential
long-term homes for migrants in Rwanda
and she said I really like your interior
designer I need some advice for myself
I mean
is that a bit tone deaf we're talking
here about families children like making
a dangerous journey and being sent to
Rwanda to live long term
in temp in this housing well I I think
that what you can actually see you can
see it for uh this picture I think she's
with Ninja Earley there but the um
this is about people having a safe and
secure place to go so contrary to some
of these characters
contrary to some of this
characterization of the policy this is
about making sure there is somewhere
safe and secure for people to go to and
actually the purpose of a home
secretary's visit was to further
strengthen our relationships with Rwanda
so people should feel confident in this
policy that ideally people would come to
this country on Route and they'd get
they'd claim asylum in the first safe
country they come to they could do so in
France Belgium and so on if they cross
the the channel they can't remain here
they'll either go back to their home
country or they go to around you and you
can see from that that isn't this is a
perfectly safe and secure place for
people to go to is it safe for everyone
in Rwanda the home office did an
equality impact assessment for the
policy uh last year they found that
there are concerns over the treatment of
gay and lesbian people there and that
the ill treatment is more than a one-off
is it safe for everyone yes I am
confident that it is is safe for people
and actually the United Nations for
example has used a Rwanda as a refugee
destination and through our engagement
with the Rwandan authorities and
government we are confident that people
will be safe there this is concerns by
the your own equality impact assessment
well I'm of course quality impact
assessments are produced for every
policy and then it's up to ministers to
consider that now I'm confident the Home
Secretary will have considered that and
I'm confident that because of the
discussions we've had with around us
because of the fact the United Nations
uses Rwanda that this is a safe place
for people to go to but in all of this
these are not easy decisions these are
difficult decisions but they're being
done for a purpose which is to stop the
boats and we have to do this to restore
control to our migration system
um Sola bravman in a recent article in
the Daily Mail wrote unless we act today
the problem will be even worse tomorrow
there are 100 million people just placed
around the world unlikely billions more
eager to come here if possible
billions more
is that right well it is a a function of
the global economy and differences in
levels of development that countries
like the United Kingdom France Germany
United States and others have
potentially vast numbers of people who
wish to come here as economic migrants
secondly secondly if you let me finish
this point secondly it is the case that
if you look at the numbers we we were at
a situation where there were dozens of
boats three or four years ago we're at
forty thousand uh last year projected to
rise further we have to be willing to
put a stop to this and there are very
very large numbers of people who could
potentially wish to enter the United
Kingdom and indeed other developed
countries uh for for economic migration
reasons 40 000 you say
you're taking two things slightly out of
context so what she's making the she's
making the point which is
perfectly correct which is that these
numbers are increasing very very rapidly
and if we don't take action the the
numbers could increase and increase and
increase again and the potential pool of
people which I think is what she's
referring to with the the billions is
the fact that if you look at a global
population of I think of about 8 billion
people many billions of those people are
not in economically developed countries
like our own so could potentially wish
to migrate for economic reasons and I
think that that's the the argument she's
making I mean Gary lineker likened this
kind of language to that use in 1930s
Germany but I think that's deeply
offensive and there's somebody who
represents a community with a very large
number of of Jewish people in it the
these the comparison between policies by
this government to legitimately stop
dangerous illegal migration and the
evils of the Nazi regime I find it
hauling that people could draw parallels
between the two of them and deeply
offensive right we need to move on to
other issues and now you're announcing
an emergency alert system that will come
to people's mobile devices just explain
what the idea is here so the idea of
this is that in a situation where there
is a serious risk to life people will
receive an alert on their phone it's
basically just broadcast from mobile
phone masks and can be reduced to an
award level and you only receive that in
the most serious of circumstances and it
will warn you about action that you need
to take this is one tool in the toolkit
that the government has to deal with the
most serious situations and it could be
that that alert could save your life now
I don't expect this to be used very
often in fact I hope it isn't used at
all but as part of our preparedness for
it we will be having a trial in about
months time on the 23rd of April so
everyone will hear their phone Buzz it's
quite a loud siren for about 10 seconds
there's no need for anyone to to do
anything but that's just a test to make
sure that it can reach everyone's phone
and this capability can reach up to 90
of people so it's an important tool to
help us deal with resilience what kind
of scenarios do you expect it to be used
in well I think it will only be used in
very serious situations where there is a
significant risk to life so I would
think for most people they wouldn't
expect to hear this Buzz possibly not
ever or certainly not for a few years it
broadly replicates what happens in other
countries so for example the United
States Japan the Netherlands and and
what really would be it would be for
things like natural disasters
potentially terrorist incidents is that
correct at all yes but it would depend
on the individual circumstances so take
an example for example if there's a very
severe flooding situation where your
home is at risk of being inundated and
your life could be in danger if you
remove remain in your home in that area
you will receive an alert in respect of
Terror incidents it will depend on the
operational advice that we receive from
the counterterra police and others
because clearly it will depend on the
circumstances it may well not be
appropriate to have a loud Alert in in
some situations uh in in others it could
be the case that a warning is required
and now lots of our viewers this morning
the one thing they're going to want to
know more than any other thing is what
is going on with public sector strikes
now the governments and talks with the
teaching unions and also Junior doctors
I believe
can you tell us what's going on
well first of all in respect to What's
called the agenda for for change so that
covers nurses ambulance works and so on
we make good progress we've we've
reached what I believe is a fair deal
and that will go to their memberships
and I hope their memberships will will
accept that in respect of the teachers
those discussions are ongoing with the
education secretary in respect of the
junior doctors our door remains open for
those discussions and we've had some
initial contact with them but but formal
negotiations are are not ongoing but I
would very much hope that those can
happen and that we can get to a
situation where we have a a decent pay
deal for public sector workers but one
that respects our public finances and
respects the pressure on inflation I
think that that's what we've got to with
the agenda for change Workforce and I
hope it's where we could get to
elsewhere are you optimistic with the
teaching talks because obviously lots of
parents have seen a lot of disruption
with schools closing yes no indeed I
I've seen that disruption yourself and I
very much hope that we can get to a
situation where it's resolved we will
just have to wait and see how those
negotiations go I really don't want to
understand them one way or the other you
do talk about the agenda for change
group rather
um there has been a breakthrough
obviously that's going to go to the
membership with the five percent payers
for nurses plus a one-off payment this
year there is a bit of concern about how
this is going to be funded though um if
you look at the submission of evidence
from the Department for health this was
to the independent pay of your body this
year they said funding is available for
pay Awards up to 3.5 percent pay Awards
Above This level would require
trade-offs for Public Service delivery
or further government borrowing
obviously the pay award we're talking
about here is five percent so are these
Traders going to happen in elsewhere in
the NHS budget uh well as you say first
of all there's the three and a half
percent uh already there so it's a
remaining amount this is fairly standard
practice for for reaching additional
public uh expenditure requirements the
NHS has a budget of uh 100 will go up to
160 billion pounds we're clear that we
won't uh affect Frontline Services by
doing this so there won't be any cuts to
NHS Services it will have to be
delivered through efficiency or from
wider savings across government it is
perfectly normal to work through that
process but indeed it does illustrate
the challenges all this finally this
money is not easy but we think that in
this context of ensuring that we reward
nurses properly and we prevent
disruption that we can find the money to
do this but it won't be easy I mean so
it's existing budgets effectively the
health secretary on Thursday said it
won't come from areas of the budget that
impact on patients
I'll be honest I really find this very
hard to get my head around can you
explain what areas of the NHS budget
doesn't impact patients well I would say
two things so first of all it doesn't
necessarily have to come uh within the
uh the envelope for the the NHS of the
160 billion pounds is the wider
Department of Health budget and there's
The Wider budget across all of
government and it's usual to work
through with the treasury to find where
those positions
so if you just let me finish on this
um on on this point but even within the
160 billion for the NHS not all of that
is going to be for Frontline uh services
so the Frontline Services we think about
are of course your hospitals your
doctor's surgeries and so on within a
budget that large the it is there is
potential to get efficiencies
because it does feel right my point is
that anywhere in the department for
health if you're talking about for
example social care that does have an
impact on patient care as well we know
know the link between social care and
the NHS we talk about efficiency savings
well anyone who tries to get an
appointment and realizes the lengthy
process it takes to takes admin in the
NHS also impacts patients it feels quite
disingenuous to me to say that it won't
impact patient care well given the
pressure that health services around the
world are under we're not going to take
Services away from the the front line I
don't deny for minutes over your point
which is that it is challenging to find
this money this is why the government
held out for so long in respect of these
negotiations because there wasn't some
huge amount of money that we could turn
to but that I am confident that we we
can find it either within the NHS
budgets or wider government uh spending
okay now next week on Wednesday we're
going to have a vote on the brexit deal
the so-called Windsor framework
are you optimistic the dep are going to
come on board
well look that's that's a matter for the
uh for the the dup I hope that they uh
will come on board but I really don't
want to preempt decisions that they're
going to make but I think what you you
have seen and indeed you've seen this
with the Windsor agreement many other
things that has come done has done we
are getting a grip of challenges facing
this country many people said it
wouldn't be possible to achieve the kind
of treaty changes we've achieved to
ensure that there is effectively no
border for goods East-West between
Mainland Great Britain and the rest of
UK United Kingdom Northern Ireland that
in turn those actions by the Prime
Minister have commanded widespread
support across different political
parties and across the conservative
party so I'm confident that the vote
will succeed and pass and I hope we will
do so with the support of the DU P But
ultimately that is for them uh now next
week let's be honest on Wednesday it may
all be completely overshadowed by the
Boris Johnson show because he is going
to be in front of the Privileges
committee investigating whether or not
he misled Parliament over partygate now
now according to the Sunday Telegraph
his team are preparing to unveil
bombshell evidence to exonerate him that
will show in their words he was advised
to say what went on what he went on and
said
and it sounds a little bit like he's
preparing to throw his AIDS onto the bus
well I'm I'm sure that first of all I
should say this is a matter for the the
house authorities and for the relevant
uh committee and uh it's not really for
ministers to give running commentaries
on these things but I'm sure uh Boris
Johnson will give a robust defense of
himself and then it will be for the
committee to to determine the outcome of
it it's not helpful is it though
well this this is a process that was
initiated by the House of Commons and of
course the house comms is entirely at
Liberty to to make whatever decisions it
it wants to I'm sure the uh former prime
minister Boris Johnson will provide a
robust defense and it will be then up to
the the committee to make their
determination
um according to reports is going to
offer conservative MPS of free votes uh
if the Privileges committee finds
against Boris Johnson would that be the
right thing to do well the standard
practice in on what we call house
matters so matters that are being led by
their the the House of Commons that
relate to these sort of things it is
standard practice not to whip the vote
um I don't I'm not sure final decisions
have been made but that would be the
precedent that you would expect to
follow that's not going to really help
her allies of Boris Johnson right
well it's a fairly well established
principle that we don't interfere in
in-house business because as I said I'm
sure that Ross Johnson will provide a a
robust defense and it will be for the
the committee to make determination and
then just finally you're obviously close
to where she's unac I think you probably
describe yourself as a friend
how would you describe his feelings
towards Boris Johnson
I think actually he has a a lot of
respect for Boris Johnson indeed I think
any prime minister and I've seen this
with I've had the privilege of knowing a
number of premises when they become
Prime Minister they realize quite how
demanding the job of being prime
minister is and have respect for all of
their predecessors and and he has that
respect for Boris Johnson as well